elon musk is not only the richest man in
the world but now he has a brand new job
recently elon disclosed that he spent
about three billion dollars to acquire
9.2 percent of twitter everyone loves
using twitter but there's lots of
problems whether they're censoring free
speech or they're simply kicking people
off of the platform elon wanted to do
something about it so he spent three
billion dollars of his own personal
money he's now the largest shareholder
of the company and just yesterday i was
saying to people twitter should lean
into this rather than fight with the
richest man in the world instead make
him the chief meme officer do something
so that you can actually use all of the
marketing opportunities that come when
you get a billionaire meme lord to hold
your stock well this morning we all woke
up to brand new news twitter leaning in
heavy ceo perag went forward and tweeted
and he said that he's excited to share
that they are appointing elon musk to
the twitter board of directors through
conversations with elon in recent weeks
it became clear to us that he would
bring great value to our board perak
continued saying that he's both a
passionate believer and an intense
critic of this service which is exactly
what we need on twitter and in the
boardroom to make us stronger in the
long term welcome elon elon of course
quickly responding on twitter with the
following where he said looking forward
to working with prague and the twitter
board to make significant improvements
to twitter in coming months now i love
this could not only is elon obviously
the richest man in the world not only is
twitter an amazing service but elon's
literally running polls on a daily basis
asking whether users want an edit button
or whether they think that free speech
is being protected on the platform or
not these polls are getting millions of
people voting and so to see twitter
officially come out and actually add
elon to the board of directors it's a
pretty important step
ultimately elon musk is one of the best
entrepreneurs of our generation he might
go down as one of the best entrepreneurs
ever
and now he's joining the board of
directors at twitter he will have
incredible influence and hopefully many
of the ideas in the community from the
users and from elon himself will start
to be implemented twitter struggled to
make money the stock price has lagged
what many people think is an important
service and hopefully the recent stock
performance of up about 30 since elon
disclosed this new position in twitter
stock
hopefully this is just the start where
twitter can become just as good of a
business as it is a product hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time